la pesée ce dernier moment avant de
monter sur le ring où les boxeurs se
jaugent du regard il leur reste 24
heures avant de faire parler la poudre
pendant que les combattants amateurs
ouvre le bal adila mohammadi entre peu à
peu dans son combat à l'abri des regards
son entraîneur antoine farrugia délivre
ses derniers conseils cette deuxième
confrontation face à cédric bellais que
l'élan pour toi déjà battue en 2010
commence par un round d'observation dès
la seconde reprise le comorien d'origine
est plus offensif que son adversaire il
contrôle le cogneur tahitien qui n'a pas
les armes pour le faire tomber
adila mohammadi est déclaré vainqueur à
l'unanimité des juges
il conserve sereinement son titre
national des super moyens
j'ai à partir du second du second j'ai
commencé à saisir la stratégie qui avait
pu mettre en place ensuite moi
je serai s'est basé sur la mienne sans
forcément prendre de risque et
puis on a fait le combat comme ça on
s'en prend des risques on a des combats
du début à la fin j'irai pour le dernier
combat le palais des sports d'el en
cours est prêt à exploser à l'image de
l'invaincu marvin petit il ne connaît
pas son adversaire joël durand mais le
jeune boxeur élan courtois est prêt un
peu stressé c'est c'est normal et un peu
de stress mais bon un coup qu'on est
monté sur le ring c'est sa part c'est un
ici parti veut un combat de marvin petit
part dès son entrée dans la salle
à chacune de ses sorties le protégé
d'antoine farrugia assurent le spectacle
prêts à faire tomber l'adversaire qui va
se présenter devant lui sur le ring et
comme un signe
il arbore déjà le short tricolore les
spectateurs vont d'ailleurs en avoir
pour leur argent
la foudre s'abat sur joël durand en
quelques secondes
soirée historique pour le boxing club de
saint quentin désormais le seul club
français à posséder deux champions de
france ou dans ses rangs